Welcome to "Ear Biscuits," the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about life
for a long time!
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're tackling the question
what would be our ideal
wild animal companion?
Yeah, and you may think to yourself,
"Why would you be worried about that?"
It's not that we're worried.
We're obsessed all of a sudden.
We both experienced something via a screen
that has now piqued a certain interest
that I didn't know I had.
This all goes back to, well,
how you may have experienced it
through the lens of my social media.
Shout-out to rhettmc on Twitter.
Okay.
I Tweeted
a while back, "Netflix got me
crying over a damn octopus,"
and I used the octopus
emoji, which, don't think
I've ever used it in any context.
Oh, you used the emoji?
Why not?
Did you type octopus,
and then it popped up,
and you're, like, "Oh, there's an emoji?"
Well, of course.
Yeah 'cause you didn't know.
I wouldn't have known that was a-
Yeah, yeah, and I was, like-
I don't know how to find an
emoji if it doesn't pop up.
There's certain times
when I'm, like, thinking,
"I feel like this conversation
calls for an emoji,
but I'm so inadequate."
You do the visual search
through all the options?
Because that's happened
to me a couple times.
Yeah, and then that's just soul-crushing,
and then you're, like, you know what?
Is this a food or a traffic sign?
This is not me.
This is not who I am, and then I just.
You leave it off.
I leave it off.
Well, um-
But if it pops up,
I'm, like, "Oh, an octopus!"
And Twitter will do that for you.
So we're, of course, talking
about the Netflix documentary
"My Octopus Teacher,"
which I watched and then
Came to work the next day.
told Link about.
And you were just gushing about this,
this Netflix documentary.
Right, so we're gonna talk about that,
and we're also gonna talk
about some other animal friendships,
and then we're gonna
talk about, like we said
at the beginning, the
wild animal friendships
that we might want to
personally instigate.
Now, let me say spoiler alerts
forthcoming because,
actually, spoilers forthcoming
is a spoiler alert.
You might wanna go and
watch "Octopus Teacher."
It's called "My Octopus
Teacher," on Netflix.
Now, we're gonna discuss
it in great detail.
I do not think that anything
that we're gonna say is going
to make it where you don't
want to then also watch it,
But, but.
but, if you don't want,
if you're a spoiler-averse person,
you wanna go watch it right now.
Not even that, I would even,
you know, it's, I think,
yeah, there's a couple
of things in the documentary
that I just wanna speak about
plainly, that I do think
it's better to experience
cold, which is why I
did not tell my family-
You were talking to Christy about it.
It wasn't at work, or maybe
it was at work, and then-
No, no, I was talking
about it when we had our,
actually, I invited you and your wife
over to take a dip in the hot tub.
Oh, yeah, that's when you were talking
about the hot tub.
The first sorta, like,
hot tub dip of COVID there.
And then I,
I went back home, and I
think it was that night,
or it's maybe the next night, and Christy,
poor girl, she has gotten herself into a
binge-watching spree of "One Tree Hill."
I didn't get her permission
to talk about this.
There's only one way
to get somebody outta that.
Is with an octopus.
Octopus.
Eight limbs to pull you
out of "One Tree Hill."
She goes to bed a lot
earlier than me on a weekend,
and so I'll burn the midnight
oil, and I'll watch something,
and I was, you know, she was upstairs,
and she went upstairs earlier, and I was,
like, "What you doing?"
She's like, "Oh, I think I'm just
gonna watch "One Tree Hill."
I was like, "Okay, okay.
I'm not going to watch that.
That's your, that's the thing that-"
And you know what,
there's a lotta nostalgia.
I'm not gonna make fun of her
for watching this thing.
She's seen it all before.
Well, she said, "You know what?
Turns out, I haven't seen it all.
She didn't finish it?
I would just catch it
when I caught it, but it wasn't
a binge thing."
It was
before the days of binging.
And now, she's, like, putting
all the pieces together
and reliving her, I
think we were newlyweds
when she watched that.
How many pieces
are there to put together?
I mean, there's just
one tree and one hill.
It turns out there's a
surrounding community
and lots of, I don't know,
there's basketballs involved,
and there's a kid.
There's a couple with-
Multiple basketballs?
I don't know how many,
but I went downstairs,
and I watched the "My Octopus Teacher,"
and then the next morning, she's like,
"What did you end up doing?"
And I told her, and she was
like, "I wanted to watch that!
Rhett wouldn't shut up about it,
and I kinda wanted to watch it!"
My wife was upset that I
watched it without her,
but, you know, I got into it not knowing
how impactful it was
gonna be on me personally.
I did not tell her anything about it
that you hadn't already told her,
and I didn't tell the kids anything,
but we got the kids to watch
it, and I watched it again.
Twice!
I watched it twice,
homie!
Was it good the second time?
It was good the second time,
and I rarely watch
anything the second time,
and it was still good, so I-
I just wanna give people permission.
Yeah, there's permission to not listen.
I'm not a spoiler-averse
person, and I know you are.
I am.
But so if you're like me-
And I'm even saying you can,
you can still listen to
us and then watch it.
Right, what I'm saying is-
But it's not ideal.
Some, 'cause I don't like telling people
who've just tuned in, to
use an antiquated term,
to this podcast to then
go enjoy some other media.
That's just not good business,
Link.
That's not good business.
So I'm just saying that you can go
and watch it if you really want to,
But if you're listening-
but watching it
and seeing it from the
perspective of the filmmaker
is going to be much better
than us talking about it.
And then you should come
back and listen to us.
So if you, again, what I was trying to say
was it's not just about spoilers,
is if you know you're
looking for things to watch
and you're committed to listening to this,
and you promise that
you're gonna come back
and listen to this, if you promise,
then I'm gonna say, "You know what,
stop this right now,
Yeah, if you come back.
and do it in that order."
Right.
But we're also gonna talk
about other things.
If we set you free, if it's
true love, you will come back.
We both have other stories
that are in a similar vein
of the "Octopus Teacher."
Unlikely animal/human, like,
legitimate friendships.
Yeah.
Like, friendships
that are kinda mind-blowing,
that I did not know were possible.
And now that we do, it might change
the trajectory of our lives.
And entire lives.
But we're gonna talk about that stuff too.
I got, I got some, I've read up on some.
You've read up on some.
So we're gonna get to that, but I'm mostly
gonna dig deep into my
soul because that seems
to be what happens in these situations.
Something happens on the soul level
when people spark friendships
with wild animals.
Did you weep during "My Octopus Teacher"?
I felt the pressure to weep
because you not only Tweeted about it,
but then you talked about it at length.
I think we've established
that it doesn't-
And I didn't.
It doesn't take much for me to weep
while watching something.
I weep during commercials occasionally.
I wept-
But you've learned why.
I've learned why?
Right?
I thought from therapy, you learned why.
Well, it's a combination.
I don't wanna bait you here.
No, it's a combination of two things.
Number one, I am actually in
the, I don't know the name
of it, but I'm in, like,
what would be called,
believe it or not, the sensitivity
triad of the enneagram.
I don't know if that's the correct term,
but there's basically a few
numbers that are actually
significantly, I am actually
on the sensitive side
of the spectrum of people,
but I also have a personality
based in all kinds of things, you know,
that has kinda shielded
me from my emotions,
so there's this weird thing that happens,
where there's actually a very
high level of sensitivity
that is happening in me
compared to an average person,
but I have sort of a
shell of a personality
that will make you think that I'm not
experiencing the things,
and actually, I'm so good
at constructing the personality
that I can actually keep the sensitivity
and the emotions and the feelings
from my own brain, like,
hidden from myself,
and so I would've told you before therapy,
"I am not a sensitive person.
Yeah, I cry at commercials sometimes.
My dad's the same way.
He's always done that."
But that's actually a sign of that.
Yeah, and it means there's,
there is a deep level
of sensitivity that exists in my person
that has to find a way to come out
in order for me to be in equilibrium,
and so what ends up happening is often,
instead of dealing
It comes out in an octopus.
with, like, sitting there
and crying about something
that's happening to me personally,
I will see something
happening between a man
and an octopus on
Netflix and begin to weep
because there's a lotta
potential for sensitivity there.
Now, that's not to say,
it seems that I'm implying
that I cry in, like, things
that pertain to my real life,
and it's, like, that
doesn't happen either.
So I might have a couple of layers.
But anyway, now that
But you've only been going
to therapy for less
we're talking about me.
than a year.
We're, right, we're gonna,
I'm gonna divert this stream back
to the streaming of
the documentary.
So, and you'll tell me when you cried.
I have a good guess, but
I had, it was actually.
Multiple times.
Oh, okay.
Well, then, I have three guesses.
But yeah, it's, I mean,
it's gonna be my wreck
at the end of this thing.
Spoilers!
Spoiler alert, there it is.
Now, they're not gonna
hang on for the wreck!
So this thing, just to
give a little overview
via Wikipedia, just for the sake of time,
"My Octopus Teacher"
came out on the fourth
of September of this year, 2020.
It's 85 minutes long.
It's outta South Africa,
and it is in English.
"The film shows how, in
2010, Foster," who is-
Craig Foster, he's a
filmmaker that then became
the subject of this film
that uses footage he shot
and some footage that was shot
by another cinematographer
and then directed by two other people.
So "Foster began free-diving in a cold,
underwater kelp forest
at a remote location
in False Bay, near Cape
Town, South Africa."
So we're talking about the Horn of Africa,
like, the southernmost point in Africa,
which, you know, it's down there.
It's getting, it's cold,
it's getting cold down there,
and this dude would swim in the water
in just a pair of
shorts, and we're talking
about, like, not scuba diving.
And goggles.
We're talking about snorkeling.
He had, like, a snorkel and a mask, fins,
a weight belt in order to kinda get down
into the kelp forest,
and a pair of shorts.
It's called free-diving.
Free-diving.
He was holding his breath to go down,
and it was, he said the
water would get as cold
as, I had to Google the conversion,
but, like, 45 degrees Fahrenheit.
Yeah, it's actually-
And that sounds crazy to me!
It's unnaturally cold.
If you get in 60-degree
water, that's frigid-feeling.
Well, just last night,
I jumped into my pool.
As you can see, we're
the jacket boys today.
We've got on jackets.
Jacket weather is finally
here in California,
and I got into my pool last night,
and it said on the thermometer
that it was 70 degrees,
but I felt like I was
getting into a refrigerator.
So to think about, and
when we did the ice bath,
it was in the 50s.
55, 58.
So 45 degrees,
and we're talking, and it's phenomenal.
He said, at one point,
early on the documentary,
when he's, you know, he
said, "After a year,"
because he dove every day.
Every day, without exception.
"After a year," he says, "you
start to crave the cold."
I'm like, "After a year?"
I don't, you know, anything
that catastrophically numbing
and painful and death-defying.
But don't you want that?
When he said that.
I, you know, but yeah, I wanted,
if it would, like, maybe after a week,
you start to crave the cold?
After a year, you start to crave the cold?
Well, and a little, a little bit
of background that what
got him to this point,
so he was a documentary filmmaker.
He is a documentary filmmaker,
and he essentially had a
mid-life crisis, right.
He had been working on some documentaries,
and one in particular that
was, like, following a tribe
somewhere in Sub-Saharan Africa,
and, you know, he had a kid, and he began
to just kinda feel disconnected
and felt like he needed
to drop everything,
didn't know if he would
ever film anything again,
didn't know if he was gonna
pick up a camera again,
went back to the Horn of
Africa to get into the water
because his family had had a house,
which, did you see the
house that they showed
that was literally-
It was below the tidal line,
so, like, the waves crashed.
How do you build that house?
Sometimes, waves would go
into the house.
Waves would go
into the house, and we're
talking about, like,
on a cliff, not like sandy beach.
Yeah, and that's what he grew up doing,
so he went back to his roots.
He wanted to go
back to the roots.
And he would, like,
'cause he went skin-diving as a kid,
and so, he just went back there,
not filming, and then he,
he came upon an octopus,
not a special octopus,
just a normal octopus.
And in fact, what is it called?
or something?
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, I don't know what.
It's a common octopus.
That is not what it is, but
it is just a common octopus.
And so, the things that
he learned, observed,
and started to film and
share with the viewer,
were just amazing,
so, you know, I wanna get into that,
but first, we should promote some merch.
Oh, yeah!
Let's get it outta the way.
Okay, let's do that.
At this point.
Do you know Chunk?
I do know Chunk.
Got a sweatshirt and a T-shirt.
It took Chunk a while
to talk us into actually
To get some merch.
launching, you know,
selling some merch for them,
But it's the type of thing
you could wear.
They're so relentless,
how often they contact us and ask us
all these ridiculous
things, but we said, "Okay,
now that you don't really
make many appearances
on our channels anymore, now is the time
to begin selling your merch."
Well,
here's the thing: if
you're a fan of Chunk,
you'll enjoy wearing this,
but it's also a cool thing
to wear because people will
think that it is a real band,
and it just seems just on
the cusp of believability,
so it would spark either strange looks
or maybe even a conversation.
That's dangerous.
Yeah, the Chunk World Tour.
Only at amazon.com/mythical.
Now, one of the things about
octopuses, is it octopi?
Is that correct, octopi?
Through the power of the
internet, I think that most people
who have an internet
connection have learned
That they're smart.
that they're smart.
This is something that,
like, five years ago,
maybe most people didn't know,
but now most people are, like,
"Yeah, I seen that crazy video
where the octopus, like, changes color."
I didn't know that octopuses could,
octopi could change color and could do
weird things like walk on two legs and-
Sprout horns over their eyes.
And then I also didn't
know that if you're doing
the IQ thing, the animal IQ thing,
that these things would actually rank
just a little bit above
a dog in intelligence,
which seems nuts to
me, and on top of that,
two-thirds of their cognitive
power is in their limbs.
Wild, I mean, they evolved
on a completely different
Branch.
branch, and, you know,
when we were hanging
out, and you were gushing
and gushing and gushing about it,
Like an octopus shooting out ink.
Mike, our friend, ended
up saying, he was, like,
"You know, the way that
they're so intelligent,
if they, the way that they evolved,
if they didn't live, if they only-"
Why can't I put this thought together?
"They only live a year.
If they lived as long as we
do, evolutionarily speaking,
they would be running the earth."
They would have developed technology,
and they would have
vehicles to come on land
and farm everywhere and
create the internet.
That's why it's so remarkable
We'd be nothing.
that in the movie
"Arrival," the alien beings
are octopus-like, and I thought
that was super, you know, appropriate.
The balancing factor
for me is that they're
Beautiful. Oh.
Gross.
Not beautiful to me.
I'm like, "Oh, gosh!"
Like, the first thing I
told you was, like, "Yeah,
but when I think about an octopus,
I think about them being able to squeeze
through tight places because they're just
so gelatinous, and I just get this, I-"
When I went to the aquarium,
and I saw one put all
of its arms through this little hole,
and I was, like, "What are you doing?"
And then all of a sudden,
it, like, the bulbous head
of the octopus, it just
kinda started shoving
its own head through this hole, and that
was very disturbing to me.
I was, like, "You're gonna get stuck!
No one's gonna be able
to yank you outta there,"
and it was just, but then it
effortlessly went through,
but it was just, like, gross!
I think the thing that's
scary to me about them,
first of all, they're scarier on land
than they are in the water
'cause they're not moving
very gracefully, but there's
also, and I don't know if I-
They're not typically on land,
but there was a scene
where this one was on land.
When you see the videos
where, like, they get caught
in a net, and then they try
to get back into the ocean,
and it's kinda crazy, there's some good
YouTube videos about that.
Yeah, flapping around.
But I think there's a movie, an old movie,
where there's, like, an octopus
that's killing a bunch of people.
It may be a squid, but there's a beak.
It's called "Octopussy."
It's a James Bond film.
There's a beak in there, up in them.
Like, if you were to take
Underneath.
the legs and, like, expose it,
Yeah.
which doesn't happen
in this particular documentary,
there's a mouth in there that
is powerful and can do things,
and I'm scared of things
like that, like beaks.
He talks about how there's
a, he calls it a drill,
where he can drill a hole into a shell,
at a very particular spot,
that will make the mollusk
or whatever that's inside just,
like, let go of the shell,
and then-
Well, it injects it
with some kinda venom that paralyzes it.
At a certain spot, yeah.
But it's gotta be
a very particular part of
the snail inside the shell.
Okay, so to continue the story,
he dives every single day for a year,
and then at some point, he
just runs into this octopus,
and he realizes that, okay, so octopuses,
this is another thing I didn't know.
Octopuses, I'm gonna say octopuses.
I know it's wrong, but I
just, octopi sounds stupid.
Octopuses have dens,
so there's, like, a place
at a particular rock,
under a little rock,
where this thing lives
An octopus garden.
and returns,
an octopus garden, and he's, like, okay.
In the shade.
"This is where I live, and
this is where I'm gonna be
every time you come and see me."
So he's like, "Okay, this is cool."
And he decided to go
there every single day,
and in the opening of the documentary,
there's a sound bite
of him saying something
like, "And there, but there was a boundary
that I discover that
you just don't cross,"
and I'm like, "Is he gonna, is he gonna,
is he gonna expose
himself to this octopus?"
I thought that he was gonna potentially
make love to the octopus,
but then I was like,
I don't think this would be on Netflix.
Because you hear about the scientist
who had the relationship with the dolphin,
and there was a sexual component,
or at least there was,
like, a, there was a,
there was a masturbation
component in order
to get the dolphin to be more compliant,
and today, we're not talking about that.
We're not saying anything,
That's next week.
but it did conjure those
fears among my brain cells,
but that's not what they meant,
but we can get back to that.
The boundary was a relational one,
and there's also a
documentarian part of this thing
because, I mean,
It's a feat of filmmaking.
the fact that, like, the
things that he observed,
like he observed the octopus
using, wanting to inspect
the human, and then using
a shell as a shield,
and then slowly approaching behind,
like, holding it up like a
shield, and then finally-
Sticking another tentacle out.
And finally making contact with him,
and then realizing that
there's a curiosity
on the part of this octopus
that he never named.
I mean he never gave the octopus a name.
I think that's a good point.
It's a good observation.
I think,
and that's the boundary, I think.
Part of the boundary was
he didn't name the octopus.
He wasn't trying to make it,
he wasn't trying to make
it a pet, and he was also,
as you will see in a second,
not trying to insert himself
into the natural flow of nature
that was going to happen
with this octopus.
We can gush all day about
all the things we learned
about octopi, but you can get
that from the documentary,
but the thing that was interesting was,
I mean, he could see the octopus predator
swimming around, that pyjama shark,
and then he was scared,
and he would go back every day,
like, "What's gonna happen?"
And then, freaking, he films
a shark attack, his friend the octopus!
I mean, they were, they
had a bond at this point!
The octopus knew him, would come out.
They would swim together.
You know, he would, like, swim on his,
the octopus would, she would
hold onto his hand, and-
And it would, like, the
octopus would come up
and settle on his chest-
And give him a hug!
'Cause he's not wearing a wetsuit.
That's part of the deal.
He wanted to be as close
to nature as possible,
so this almost naked man has this octopus
just nestling on his chest!
He didn't reach out, grab the octopus,
and put him on his chest.
No, the octopus did it.
He let the octopus instigate.
Take the initiative.
But you left out an
important point, which was
he was filming it.
Once he was like, "Oh, I'm
gonna start filming this thing.
I'm gonna take my camera down there."
He had developed this trust, this bond,
and then it was following
him, and he dropped a lens
off of the camera, and
it spooked the octopus,
and it did not go back to its den.
So the next day, he goes back.
The thing is not in its den.
He goes back the next
day, it's not in its den.
He's like, "Oh, crap, I've
ruined this relationship.
We had built this trust,"
and that
You broken up.
was the first time I cried.
I was already crying when he had the bond,
and then he broke the bond.
Oh, so you didn't cry when he successfully
tracked her down and reconnected?
Oh, no, I cried again then.
That's number two?
Yeah.
Well then, was number three,
I mean-
It was at least three times.
I mean, the big point of horror
was him filming this shark
Getting attacked.
attack her
and rip off one of her arms
and just eat it, and then
it gets to that boundary
because he didn't stop it from happening,
but then he says, "I couldn't resist,"
basically, he couldn't resist helping,
so he, you know, she's in, she's holed up
in her-
She makes it back
to the den.
Yeah, on her own.
With seven limbs.
He's tempted to help, but he doesn't help.
He just films her going back to her den,
limping with one less arm,
which has her brain it it.
Yeah, lost a part of her brain.
And then she's, like, she's
too weak to even change color.
Yeah, she just turns white.
And so, but he did crack open shells.
Like some mussels or something.
Mussels or something, and serve it to her
to have some nourishment.
And she took it.
She took it, but he said,
"I don't think it did
much good," but I think he
might've been saying that
because he crossed his own
boundary, which I'm like,
"Dude, you know, when
you're in a relationship
with an animal, all bets are off."
Like, it's not a pet, but
there was a bond there,
and he freaking, yeah,
I totally understand
that he had to, like, do
what he could to help,
but it seemed like a little
too little, too late,
until she freaking grew her arm back.
Did you, I didn't, I forgot
that that was possible.
I didn't know it was possible.
My jaw dropped.
She grew the arm back, and
so she had eight limbs again,
and she kinda came back to life,
and again, so he lost contact with her,
tracked her down, learned
how to track her movements
by looking at the sand on
the bottom of the ocean,
reunites with her, watches
her get attacked by the shark.
She loses the limb, and then
she gets back in business,
and then sort of the, it goes on
and on and on.
The relationship continues.
And then,
lo and behold, the same
dang gone shark comes back,
or one of the sharks
that hunts at this reef,
comes back, and this point,
this is when my mind started-
I was like, "Am I
experiencing reality correctly
at this point?"
Yeah.
Because the octopus
has the ability to pick up
all these shells
and ball itself up and shield itself.
It looks like a soccer ball that's made
out of all these shells that it's holding,
and there's a name for that as well.
I can't remember what it
was, and the shark comes up.
I do not think that this
behavior was ever documented
before he observed it.
'Cause he says he remembered seeing that.
The first time he ever came
in contact with the octopus,
it was in that state of this
soccer ball with the shells,
and he was, like, "What
the hell is this thing?"
And then he realized it's an
octopus protecting itself.
And then there's, like,
epic battle with a shark
that still is trying to eat
the soccer ball of shells.
And then, okay, two things,
two remarkable things happen
during the shark attack.
The first thing that
happens is that once this,
the shark picks up the octopus
and is shaking it around
'cause it realizes, "Okay,
this isn't a soccer ball.
This is an octopus," but
the octopus gets away
and swims out of the
water, gets on the shore
on a rock,
and eventually has to
get back in the water
because it can't stay out too long,
and at that point, it
gets on the shark's back
and rides the shark because it knows
that the shark can't eat
it as long as it's riding
on it like it's a freaking horse.
But it rode it as a soccer ball of shells.
Yeah, right, it kept itself in the shells
while it did this.
So that the shark
was totally confused, and
then when it brushed up
against some coral,
it just, ever so
normally, it just brushed
itself off and floated away.
This thing is so freaking smart,
and that's why you observe this thing
every day for a year, and
you're making this bond with it,
and you're saying, "Okay,
I'm now going to film
my best ocean friend getting eaten alive."
How much do you think was, of the footage
that we were seeing in the documentary,
was the footage that was
captured in the moment
when it happened, and how
much was, like, filler,
like, filling it, going
back and filming later
to make it make sense?
Like pickups, like movie pickups?
Like, I do think the
octopus is smart enough
to comply to pickups.
Like, "Hey, can you get on the back
of that pyjama shark again?"
And you know, it's like, "We're gonna look
at the continuity photos.
You're gonna get the same shells
in the same place."
'Cause every single thing
that would happen,
I think he captured
all of it,
they would, he had
incredible shots of it!
And I think that was a level of obsession
that I totally understand.
It's like, again, you're making this bond,
and then you don't know what's
going to happen every day,
and it's like, "Is this
the day that I come back,
and the octopus is just
not there, you know,
has been attacked and is just gone?
Am I gonna have to track it again?"
But that's why it's so amazing to me
that he didn't intervene
except in that one breach,
you know, with feeding,
and then it, you know,
comes back, and it's like
there's another octopus,
they're mating, they've mated,
and then it's like he knows
that she's gonna die at that point,
so he's coming back every day to see.
That's the end of the lifecycle.
Yeah, only a year, something that smart.
At what point in the process do you think
that the inner filmmaker,
there's a spark sometimes,
especially when you're
doing documentary film,
there's a spark.
We don't have a whole lot
of experience with this,
but I do remember it when we were making
"Looking for Ms.
Locklear," which is really
the only documentary we've ever made,
full-length documentary, and once
the search for our teacher
became much larger, it became
about the struggle of the Lumbee people,
and, like, we found
ourselves in Washington, DC,
at a hearing, filming John McCain
talk about, you know, and
the Indian Affairs Committee.
There was this moment,
somewhere along the lines,
where I was, like, "We've
got something here," right?
He was, at what point do
you think he understood
the potential for what he was creating?
I mean, he was a nature documentarian.
I think it had to be pretty early,
and I do think that was the factor
because I'm not that familiar with him,
but I have to believe
that there's these rules
of you don't intervene, you know.
Well, there's the famous
photo that won a prize
of some sort, whatever the photo prize is,
of the starving child.
Right.
I don't even remember what it was from.
So there's a journalistic
principle that applies
to nature as well that's like-
Well, and just to complete
the thought, though, there's
a picture of a starving child
that was walking to get
food, and this journalist,
photojournalist, took
a picture of the child
but did not assist the child,
and I think the story goes
that the child died, and when
people found out about that,
they were like, "Well,
okay, what's more important:
your journalistic principles
or the life of this child?"
This isn't a child, this is an
octopus we're talking about,
but there is this sort of commitment
to these journalistic
principles that he went
into the process knowing that,
like, "If I'm gonna make this
into something, I understand
the type of criticism
that I'm gonna receive, especially
when it's an animal,
for intervening," right?
And he really, he held strong.
I couldn't have done
that, and I found myself
being angry with him, when the octopus
was in that epic battle as a boulder.
'Cause he coulda just reached out
and, like, slapped a shark.
But maybe that's a good
point to analyze because
an extraordinary thing was
documented that happened.
You know, it's like-
And you don't wanna see a
human hand come in there
and, like, thump the shark away.
Yeah, this is not the story, you know,
he was presenting her story,
not their story, but really?
I mean, when the directors
took the footage,
they presented his story,
but it was more about how,
you know, he had a son, and
there was a connection to,
it was what did the octopus teach him?
And there was, you know,
his takeaway was more
of a, that we're all connected.
Right, well, and it
raises a larger question,
which I think we'll get
into as we begin to talk
about some of these other scenarios,
which is what part of
this incredible connection
between this animal
that's more intelligent
than I ever understood, you know,
and I think about, you know,
my relationship with Barbara,
your relationship with Jade,
who is currently in your lap,
and definitely, I attribute human emotions
and human instincts to Barbara.
Like, when Barbara looks at me with a,
she gives me a facial expression
that may be like, well,
she's confused right now,
or she is annoyed right now,
or she's happy right now,
and again, a lotta that is me projecting
a human understanding onto a dog's face,
even though we do know that dogs
since, you know, being
domesticated, have developed
these things that only exist with them
and don't exist with
wolves, like the ability
to make sustained eye
contact with a human,
to communicate via eye contact.
That's not something that
would happen with a wolf,
but even so, it makes sense
that there is some sort
of emotional connection.
Like, I feel like when
I'm doing my stretching
in the morning, and Barbara
comes and gets on my chest
and, like, puts her head on my face
or licks me or whatever, I don't think
that she's just, "Well, I'm doing this
because you're gonna feed me later."
That might be a part of it, but I do think
that there is an
emotional component to it,
but how much of this was an understanding
that this octopus had?
Which is like, and again,
they wouldn't put it
in human terms, but, like,
how much of it do you think
was, insofar as an octopus
can consider a human a friend,
that was what was going on?
It seemed that way. It really did.
I mean, like the, he wasn't-
She, the octopus, was not
getting anything from him,
except for that one little
time, he was not feeding her.
He was not doing anything except,
like, being interesting.
You know, she was interested,
and there was a connection.
There was a form of relationship,
like curling up on his
chest and stuff like that,
or just, like, swimming together.
I mean, he witnessed her
being playful with fish.
With the fish, yeah.
You know, once you really
understand how something works,
and it's extremely, you know,
I'm so glad that we got a dog
because, you know,
until you experience a connection
with an animal, you know,
it's not something that,
it's just not something you
can judge from the outside,
and that's what I was doing, right.
It does something within
a human soul, I think,
to have a connection with an animal.
Let's get to some of these 'cause I think
that these are an
exploration of that point.
Yeah, well, I'm gonna talk about Dindim.
Tell me about Dindim.
The penguin.
So in May of 2011,
a guy named Joao Pereira de Souza,
which I will just call Mr.
De Souza from this point on.
Okay.
And I'm reading from a,
points from a CNN article
in 2016 about this.
"A humble retired bricklayer rescued
an injured penguin
Where?
in the state of Rio de
Janeiro, or Rio de Janeiro,
and the flightless bird was covered
in oil and unable to move."
So oil spill.
It was, you know, one of those situations
where you got a bird covered in oil.
So De Souza took him-
We're not talking sexy oil.
We're talking crude oil.
Right, yeah, this is
not a lubricant.
Well, it is, I guess, but you
know, yeah, not K-Y Jelly.
"De Souza took him under
his wing," ah, pun,
"and nurtured him back to health,
thoroughly cleaning oil
residue on the penguin's body
and feeding him for days
until he was fit enough
to return to the water,"
so this guy basically lives
on, like, an island nation,
lives on the beach, essentially.
Not an island nation,
an island area near Rio.
So, "He took him to another
nearby island to set him free,"
to set Dindim free,
"and later," of course,
he hadn't named him at this
point, "later that day,
he hears some squawking in his backyard,"
and he's like, "Holy crap,
the penguin is back!"
He came back
to the backyard, and he, the penguin-
Now, he wasn't, like, he
didn't put him in an enclosure.
He didn't treat him as a pet.
He did feed him, and he did touch him.
Well, this penguin stayed
with De Souza for 11 months,
and then, he shed his
annual coat of feathers,
molted, or whatever the term
is, and suddenly was gone.
Like, he was nothing but feathers?
He disappeared, no.
That penguin was just a ball of feathers!
I've been duped!
All of a sudden,
all of a sudden, he was
not in his backyard.
Okay.
So at this point,
De Souza is thinking,
"Okay, that was a weird
but awesome thing, this
short-lived relationship
with this penguin that I
nursed back to health,"
but then the next year,
he came back.
He came back.
To the backyard.
And that's when you cry in the movie.
And then he left again.
Well, he's marching.
Haven't you seen "March of the Penguins"?
They do something, right?
And for years, every year
since 2011, he has come back
to his backyard at the same time.
It's like an extended period of time.
He, like, comes back in
the middle of the summer
and stays until, like,
February, and then goes away,
and then comes back at
the same exact time, now-
It makes you cry a little, you know.
You can make yourself cry?
It makes you well up
because just imagine his,
you know, the feeling.
He did this, you know,
selfless act of rescuing-
Well, and you wanna cry, look at the-
A flightless bird.
Look at this video.
Oh, no.
And you have to describe
what you're seeing.
Here he is. This him.
He's waddling. He's waddling up.
And he just puts his, he nuzzles him.
What is he?
He puts his beak on his face,
and he doesn't do this-
He's kissing him!
He kisses him, and he doesn't do this
with any other humans.
He doesn't allow, if any other
human tries to touch him,
he bites them.
Oh, wow.
But he lets him give him baths.
Slow-mo shower!
He's giving him a shower.
And he's just letting, he's holding him.
This is a humble bricklayer, Link.
That's a humble bricklayer.
I mean, and just, and you know,
it's such a rewarding connection.
It's like you do a selfless act,
and then it's recognized.
It's like, "I owe you my life.
I'm gonna come back, and I'm
gonna nuzzle you, only you.
I am not tame. I am allegiant."
I don't wanna take any
of the magic out of it,
but I'm gonna tell you something
that has been theorized about
this particular situation.
Now the first thing is, for
those of you who are like,
"How does he know it's the same penguin?"
Well, there were some scientists
who asked the same
question, and so in 2016,
they tagged this,
they drew graffiti on him.
The penguin.
They tagged
Oh.
the penguin so they could
keep up with his location,
and sure enough, it's the same penguin,
and he travels like 5,000 miles.
Wow, but what?
But, okay, and this is from the article,
"While the idea of a
penguin returning to visit
every year seems surreal,
Krajewski," who is a scientist,
"said that most Magellanic," or-
It's like Magellan with an
I-C, "Magellanic penguins
are very loyal to their
partner and nesting site.
They nest in the same place every year
and with the same partner."
So in the circuitry of
this penguin's brain
is a commitment to
monogamy, and so one theory
is that he sees De Souza as his mate.
He sees it as another penguin, and so,
he has this tendency to bond and connect
and almost imprint on this other being,
and it just happens that, "Hey, yeah,
you guys go and you spend
time with other things
that look like birds, and you
do interesting sexual things
with them, and it makes baby penguins.
I just go hang out with
a humble bricklayer."
Boy, you should see the brick he can lay.
But still, it's beautiful, and it's sweet.
I'd like to see your mate Tammy lay brick.
Right, exactly.
You know.
That's Dindim.
I mean, I read an article
about Yoriko the fish.
In Japan,
there's this underwater shrine
sacred to the Shinto religion,
and there is a caretaker
of this shrine, so he, like,
he scuba dives down there,
Hiroyuki Arakawa,
and there's this, like,
I'll call it a ugly fish.
I'm just gonna say it.
It's a ugly, like, it's a bottle-nose,
bulbous-headed, sheepshead wrasse fish.
It's not pretty. It's no octopus.
And this thing comes up, and for 25 years,
he greets her with a kiss on the forehead,
but I watched the footage of it.
I think you watched the footage too.
A little less impressive.
It's just a big ole fish getting petted
on the forehead, and then-
It looks like it wants something.
Yeah, it looks like it wants something.
I mean, it snapped at
him, and it seemed like it
was eating something later,
but he kisses it on the head.
That doesn't count for me.
I mean, it's like, that's not special.
It's just like, "Hey, a fish knows you
are gonna show up every
day and maybe feed it
or at least kiss it on the head."
And-
I bet a little something
comes outta your mouth that it tastes.
A fish has got to be, and
this fish looks really stupid.
I mean, like, I think all
fish are probably pretty dumb.
This fish looks like especially stupid.
I mean, the fact that it's
lived 25 years, I think,
is just a testament to
you don't have to be
that smart to make it
25 years in the ocean.
But let me tell you
about this, a crocodile.
Okay.
I got another one too.
I just want, I wanna go ahead
and skip to the crocodile.
Okay, all right.
'Cause I think it's,
this is crazy.
All right.
A dude named Chito is in,
he's in Central America.
He's a fisherman.
He finds a crocodile,
like, a small crocodile
that's been shot by a farmer
'cause it was coming out.
It was coming, he has cattle,
and shot this crocodile
in the head, like, in the eye to kill it,
but then he finds it, and
he nurses it back to health
over three years.
And he's, like, chewing
stuff for this crocodile
and then giving it to,
like, showing the crocodile,
"Oh, you need to eat
this," and then, like,
feeding it stuff and, like, beans-
He's, like, demonstrating chewing?
Yeah, to a crocodile.
And it worked?
A crocodile, yeah, and this thing-
How big is this thing?
Well, it was small, but
then, over the three years
of it regaining its vigor, this
thing grew to 16 feet long.
That's a big animal.
It's a huge crocodile!
And then he named it
Pocho, and he puts it back,
and once it recovers, he sends it away,
and then he gets up the next morning,
and that thing has come
back and is in his yard.
And then he does it again,
does it three times,
and the crocodile, Pocho,
just keeps coming back
and hanging out in his yard.
He doesn't want to leave Chito.
And so, then Chito is
compelled to spend more
and more time with this crocodile,
to the point that
his wife starts to think
he's sneaking around on
him, and then it realizes
it's a crocodile but gets jealous
that he's spending his-
The wife gets jealous?
And they get a divorce.
He wasn't making love with it, was he?
No, he wasn't.
He was just spending more
time with the crocodile
than he was spending with her,
and he's quoted as saying,
"Another wife I could get.
Pocho was one in a million."
Well, you could say that again.
He did get another wife,
and they had a daughter,
and the daughter's not allowed
to, like, be around Pocho,
but Pocho will not leave, so he's spending
all this quality time and
learning all the intricacies
of, like, how the crocodile
looks and all this stuff,
and he starts swimming with the crocodile,
and there's, like, a Nat Geo documentary,
which incidentally, is
shot by the same person
who was the cinematographer
on "My Octopus Teacher."
Really?
Yeah, and
in the opening shot, you
see this huge crocodile,
like, in the water with his
eyes at the water level,
and then his mouth opens,
and you know how you'll see
a crocodile's mouth just gape open,
and then you realize no, this is not
the crocodile's mouth gaping open.
There's, like, a huge
bald head in its mouth.
No, the crocodile's mouth is shut,
and a bald-headed man, I mean, Chito,
is underneath the crocodile,
pushing his head up and revealing himself.
This is, like, the opening shot
of this Nat Geo documentary, and he, like,
he rides on its back, and he,
this is a reptile!
You would think that this couldn't happen
because again, the way that
the reptilian brain develops!
They're not that smart.
I mean, it's like, yeah, it's-
We have a number of layers of brain
on top of the core of our brain.
Basically, the reptilian
brain is just instinctual!
That's what's so crazy about the octopus
is that it's evolutionarily
so much more separated,
but yeah, a crocodile, I mean, but-
Why doesn't he eat Chito?
I mean, his name is Chito,
after all.
It is spelled differently,
but it's not as compelling
as the octopus thing
because you can't attribute
as much intelligence to
the crocodile, but, I mean,
there's enough there-
There's a lot
more risk, though.
There is a bond, and there
are many documented cases
of people, like, with, you know,
after years and years
of having a pet reptile,
and he was a pet,
but he was still free to go.
He's free to go now!
They'll turn on you and
just kill you at any point.
Didn't he die?
He died at age of 50 in 2011,
but the interesting thing
is how-
The crocodile.
The crocodile, yeah.
Chito described it as
whenever he would play
with the crocodile, he said
it was like being with God.
Like, the dude was obsessed
with this connection
because it can become
so, I'll say magical.
You're able to cross
this impossible boundary,
and it's, I mean, you could
tell in his interviews
just how meaningful it was to
him to have that connection,
and it is interesting to
explore, like, how much of that
is, you know, projection,
but it's real for him,
and it's important for him.
Well, we have a tendency, you know,
post-Enlightenment, and
especially in the Western world,
we have a tendency to do what we're doing,
which we kinda just naturally do,
which is to try to break it down
to just its naturalistic elements,
but there is-
An emotional component,
Well, I would say
it seems.
even a spiritual component,
right, potentially.
Okay.
'Cause what I'm getting at is insofar as
That's what he did, yeah.
when you talk about the
idea of oneness, right,
and the idea that consciousness
is a thing that exists.
I'm not saying I subscribe to this idea,
but it is a very intriguing
way to look at the universe,
and the idea that there
may not necessarily be,
there could be,
a God who is somehow
separate from this creation
and was the one who set everything
into motion, but to me, there's a slightly
more interesting idea that, in many ways,
seems more compelling, that
God is in everything, right,
and is sort of, the
universe is essentially
a physical expression of a
consciousness that exists
that you and I
and this wooden desk are all a part of.
This is something that I used to, when I-
And I'll just break in
and say I don't know
if it's, it may be more
interesting and compelling.
It is interesting and
compelling to me as well,
but it may be because it's a little more,
it's a newer idea to us, but-
Well, I'm gonna talk about that
because I actually feel like, I remember
when I used to hear about
different Eastern religions,
and I heard about it in the context
of growing up in a
conservative Christian home,
in a church where the way
that we would interpret,
say, Hinduism, Buddhism, whatever,
like when I learned that there
were all these specific gods
associated with different
objects in Hinduism,
to me, I was like, "That's
ridiculous," right.
I remember thinking that as a kid.
I was like, "That seems kinda,
that seems sorta archaic,
and it seems like an old kind of idea
that you would attribute, you
would find a god in a rock-"
Mystic, it was mystical.
What I'm saying is I belittled the idea.
I'm not saying that it was mystical.
What I'm saying is I
looked down on the idea.
I thought that it was a bad
way to look at the universe.
I thought that it was a simple
way to look at the universe,
and I was like, "When you can-"
Or an ignorant.
Yeah, yeah, or like,
"That kinda makes sense.
Like, maybe those people
haven't evolved to a place
where they can appreciate the idea
of a personal Creator God,"
but one of the things that I'm kinda,
I'm reevaluating again.
I don't know where I
fall in this perspective,
but when I think about that,
I'm like, "Oh, it isn't
necessarily just a
simple, super-simple sort
of dismissive view that I
had, which was attributing
a god or magic to every single thing,
but to me, it's a way
of kind of expressing
that idea that there is life.
There is God, whatever
the word you wanna use.
There is consciousness in all things,
and sort of more of a sense of fabric
of the universe, right, and so, I do think
there's been times in my life
where I have felt connected
to things that it would be like,
it's weird to feel
connected to a plant, right,
but if you go back from
a scientific standpoint
to the point where, well,
we come from the same place.
We're all stardust.
At one point, the same atoms
that make up that plant,
you know, the same atoms that make up me
are gonna become the same
atoms that make up a plant,
that make up an animal,
that make up the next Jade,
and what I'm getting at is,
are you using Jade as a
visual example right now?
I am, yeah.
And so, your connection
with Jade is, again,
the Western Enlightened view is that this
is a lesser creature that
is here for your benefit.
This is here for you.
The idea that you're human, and therefore,
you must exercise dominion
over all things on earth,
and that everything is
here for your exploitation,
there's a different way to look at things,
which is we're all part of the same system
in a much more integrated and thorough way
than we ever appreciated,
and when you think about it
like that, maybe what's
happened between Chito and Pocho
is a sort of strange,
it's an anomaly, but it's an expression
of that type of connection
that can happen between beings.
I'm not gonna swim with a
croc to find God, but he did.
Right!
He did, and
his second wife was with it, so.
Yeah!
Yeah, I mean,
it is interesting.
I do want you to get to the lion.
You know, I had heard
about this, but this is a,
the relationship narrative associated
with this, is flooring.
Well, and this is a
video that you've seen,
if you're one of the 100 million
people who have watched it.
Christian the lion.
You may have seen about 10 years ago,
there was a video that went viral,
and it's obviously, like, old footage.
It's from the late '60s, and
I think the original version
doesn't even have any
sound, but there's these two
very hippie-looking
white dudes with long
hair and bell bottoms,
and they're, like, out in Africa.
Bell bottoms, yeah.
And next thing you know,
there's a freaking lion
that still seems to be juvenile.
It doesn't have a mane yet, but it's
a freaking 500-pound creature
that could easily kill them.
Starts running up to them, and you're
like, "Oh, no, what's about to happen?"
And it jumps up, and it hugs this dude,
and then it's just, like, licking him
and hugging him and frolicking,
and then it goes up to the other guy,
and the same thing happens,
and they're, like, laughing,
and it's one of these
things, you're like, "What?"
I've seen this before,
like on "Tiger King."
You know, I've seen people
interact with big cats
that were raised in
captivity, but these guys are
in the middle of Africa, the
bush, and this thing comes out.
So the story behind this
is that, again, late '60s,
there's two Australian
dudes who see a lion cub
for sale in England 'cause there was
an exotic animals market at that time.
They purchased this thing.
They're in their early 20s.
They're not trying to take
advantage of the thing.
They're just like, "Who
knows where this thing's
gonna end up?
Let's give it a good
life," and they do this.
They raise this thing in their
apartment, in their flat,
in England, and this
lion cub grows over the course
of a year and is their pet
and stays in their house,
rides in the back of
their convertible Mercedes
everywhere they go around town,
goes to parties with them,
becomes friends with their friends,
and there's, like, an
account of him jumping up
on a woman that was one
of the lion's friends,
and he accidentally,
like, claws her dress,
and it falls to the floor, like,
all these crazy, surreal
that seems like some sort
of, like, Wes Anderson movie,
where there's this lion friend
who is going along with these guys.
Now eventually, they realize
this cannot continue.
He's too big.
He's never shown any signs
that he's gonna hurt anybody,
but he doesn't really
understand his own strength,
and it's probably not moral
to keep this thing in England.
Probably not.
So they take him to Kenya,
where they just, what, drop him off
or whatever, and at this
point, you're thinking,
"This thing has never lived in the wild.
Surely this thing's gonna die."
Well, if you watch that video,
you'll see one of the things
that happens is after they're interacting
with this male lion, all of a sudden,
a female lion comes up to
them and starts interacting
with them, not in the same
way, but it's basically
just right there next to them,
walking around.
Curious?
Curious, and, like, coming up next to them
and kinda rubbing up on them.
They put Christian the lion
in the bush and came back
three months later, thinking
they would never see him again.
Three months later?
Three months later, he
comes up to them, hugs them
like that, and then brings
them his wife, and they meet.
They stay there for nine days,
and they meet his wife and his kids.
They have a litter, whatever
the correct term, of cubs.
So he's-
That couldn't have happened
in three months, though.
Ah, I think it could.
You can have babies in three months?
Maybe if you're a lion.
I don't know what the gestation period is.
I don't know if I've
got all the facts right,
but I do know when he came back, he had,
he introduced them to his wife and kids.
He made it.
He made it. He made it, and he made it.
And then they never saw him again.
I don't know, the story kinda
ends there, but these guys,
when the video went viral in 2011,
they ended up going on,
like, "The Today Show,"
and of course, they were
much older at this point,
and then they signed a
movie deal where Zac Efron
was gonna play one of
'em, and I don't think
that ever happened because I
looked, and I couldn't find it.
Yeah, the whole captivity thing is a-
It complicates it.
Complicates this conversation,
but I mean, the fact
that there's, you know, having
a connection with an animal,
one of the things this
highlights is how extraordinary
it was with an octopus, you
know, going back to that.
You know, 'cause they're just,
you know, you might have one
in an aquarium, but you're not gonna have
an actual relationship, this connection,
and it was just, it's mind-blowing.
Does it make you think twice
I like 'em more.
about enjoying
octopus at a fancy restaurant?
It gives me an easier excuse
to not eat it.
You don't like it.
I've had it a couple of times,
And I really do like it.
and I didn't hate it, but
I've never seen it on the menu
and said, "I gotta have this."
And I am the exact opposite.
If I see it on the menu, I
order it, without exception.
If octopus is on the menu, I order it.
What about now?
Ah, man, this is tough.
Seriously? You cried three times?
Well, again, I'm not trying
to go philosophical here,
and I'm also not trying to
justify my own behavior,
but just go with me on another
little journey for a second.
Okay, okay.
Okay, and don't hold
your dog up in the middle of it.
Just stay with me.
I'm not.
I've thought about this,
and I thought about this
as it relates to the morality
of eating meat, right?
It's something, I actually think about it
on a pretty regular basis, right,
and if you follow that
sort of oneness idea
in that we're all connected,
I mean, first of all,
the distinction that we make
between plants and animals,
obviously, there is a distinction
between plants and animals.
There are some weird sort
of intermediate things,
and I do think that for whatever reason,
the closer something gets to
our level of intelligence,
for good reason, it becomes
weirder to eat it, right,
but everybody draws
the line at some point.
Some people say anything with
eyes, anything with a face.
Some people say anything
with a conscience,
as however you define
that, but there's a lot of,
there's actually a lot
of evidence to suggest
that there is a level of consciousness
amongst plants, right.
When you eat a plant, you are killing it.
You're constantly murdering microorganisms
that have some level of consciousness
just by being a person,
meaning that there is
a give and take that happens
between beings in the universe.
Now, there are some things
that you can point to
that really seem totally,
unnecessarily exploitative,
like factory farming as an example, right.
When you begin to see an animal
simply as a source of food,
and its existence is just for the benefit
of you being able to eat
exactly the right kinda beef
that you want or whatever,
and then of course,
what the net effect of
that is is that there is
an animal that is being
bred in a certain way,
in a certain environment,
that is just to be eaten,
which is different than
hey, there's a deer
that's out here enjoying its life,
doing its thing, being a part of nature.
It's going to be killed by
something eventually, right.
It's usually, animals in the wild
don't usually die of natural causes.
They end up getting eaten by predators,
and so, there are points at which a human
enters the food chain and
says, "I'm the predator,
and I'm going to."
Anyway, I believe that
you can kill an animal
for the purpose of it being food and do it
in a respectful way that is
actually respecting its life.
I think that that's a
possible thing to do.
So all that to say from
a moral standpoint,
while I understand someone
saying, "From a moral standpoint,
I will not eat animals, period,"
I think that it's a
much more complex thing
than a lotta people maybe
are willing to admit
because there's a lotta
gray in that equation.
So you will eat the octopus.
Well, I guess what I'm saying is, again,
not trying to defend
myself and justify myself,
but I honestly feel, my
perspective is I can be
absolutely amazed at the
octopus, appreciate the octopus
in a way that I never did before,
and still eat the octopus.
I don't even like having-
Like, I don't have to-
What I'm saying is, if I get to a point
where I have to disrespect an animal
in order to be able to eat
it, I'm not saying I would,
you know what I'm saying,
I don't disrespect-
I don't think that a
cow's life is pointless.
I don't think that, I
have sympathy for a cow.
I eat beef at the same
time, and you know, listen,
I may get to a point where it's like,
that contradiction is something
that is truly a contradiction
that I can't live with,
but I actually think there's
more compelling reasons
to stop eating meat than the moral dilemma
around the life of an animal, but anyway.
Well, what about this?
What animal would we each choose,
wild animal would we choose
to have a best friendship with
that would remain wild?
Not domestication, not
making a pet, not putting
in a pen or in your house
or in your convertible,
but like if you could
go into, on their terms,
be friends with that
animal, what would it be?
I really like the idea of
being, of, like, scuba diving.
I can't do this,
the skin-diving.
You could, though.
No one can do it at the
beginning. That's what I've heard.
I know, I just-
No one can
do it at the beginning.
I have an anxiety of,
like, holding my breath,
like, it's tough.
Everyone has that anxiety.
That's what I, where were we
talking about this before?
Oh, it was that book,
the book I told you about
that I wanted to do a
whole episode on that week.
We can talk about it later,
but the guy talks about it
in the book that everyone
Well, I know that.
has this underwater anxiety.
I'm saying that, but, like,
I would love to get my scuba license.
I've wanted to do that ever since I've
been snorkeling a couple of times.
I'm, like, "Man, I wanna go deeper,
but I don't wanna have to hold my breath.
Oh, yeah, there's scuba diving."
I'm actually more freaked out by the scuba
than I am the free-diving.
So I'm, well,
so I'm thinking in that realm.
It could be an octopus
for me now. It could be.
Well, I think you gotta
pick something original.
That's been done.
You have to have a "My Sea Bass Teacher."
That would be your documentary.
I mean, there's some of
the mammals in the ocean.
Any mammal in the ocean.
Or clearly, a dolphin,
a dolphin connection.
I don't know, I guess I do wanna-
Seahorse, you like little horses.
Ah, they're not smart.
Well, what if they are?
You don't know that.
What if you could have a little seahorse
that just nestles up
into your chest region?
Yeah, that's cool.
I would want one of the
bigger ones, though.
The biggest seahorse is for you.
How big do they get?
I think they can get as
big as your thigh, no.
No way a seahorse gets that big.
Maybe as big as my foot.
I don't think a seahorse gets that big.
I think they could be
Maybe at some point
in the distant past.
a size 11 foot.
US, US size 11 shoe.
You'd think they're-
Well, I gotta ask this question now.
How big
can a seahorse get?
"Can range in size from 0.6
inches to 14 inches long!"
I'm telling you, man.
That's a size,
that's a size 14.
Yeah, that's a big, that's
a big seahorse, man.
You can find a big, size 14.
Can seahorses kill humans is also-
And they, they could nuzzle
in a way that a horse would.
It says, "Might seem
like the most harmless,
unassuming creatures under the sea,
but they're actually
one of the most deadly."
Okay, forget it.
What?
Just a normal horse
on land.
You're gonna be killed
by a seahorse.
You know, I mean, people have
these connections with horses.
There's, like, therapy
associated with horses.
Like, they have this, like,
cosmic connection to people.
So I just gotta go back to a
regular horse, final answer.
What's your answer?
But it has to be a wild horse.
Yep.
It can't just be
like a horse in a stable
somewhere in Burbank.
Yeah, it has to,
I only am gonna,
Like a mustang.
I'm gonna ride it only by invitation.
Like, it's gonna have to kneel down
and kinda, like, when the
horse picked up Aragorn
when he was, like, totally
decimated, he seemed dead,
and the horse, like,
basically put him on its back,
that's how it would have to happen,
but it would after, like, a year.
Well, mine is, my animal
is horse-like in a sense,
and it's also, I think
I've been on record saying
that this is my favorite animal: giraffe.
I'm a very, I'm tall,
I'm a very large man,
and the idea,
could you imagine what it would be like
to be friends with a giraffe?
Just think about that for a second.
First of all, they're obviously
They're so tall.
gentle and sweet.
Have you seen the
eyelashes on those things?
They are also rideable, and that's not,
I'm not in this just for the ride,
but riding a giraffe would be one
of the more badass
things that you could do.
Again, this would be in the
context of a friendship.
It wouldn't be in a context of-
It would have to be
initiated by the giraffe,
I'm saying.
Yeah, there's no saddle.
I wouldn't have a saddle made.
I'd be riding this thing bareback,
and I would be holding on to its neck.
I wouldn't even be grabbing onto its hair
because I might hurt it.
It's kinda like riding
a hobby horse or, like, a carousel horse.
Yeah, and this is only if,
again, if I was invited
to ride it, but I think that
if you are in a friendship
with a giraffe, I think that's part of it.
I just think you'd be walking with it,
and it would just be, you know.
I think I might grab
on to one of its legs,
like one of those little
stuffed animal monkeys.
Like a child?
That just, like, stays on a leg,
and I just hold on to
the leg and go around,
and then occasionally, it throws me
up and lets me walk up its neck
to see what it sees.
You're kinda missing
the relationship.
I was looking for more of, like,
you would read aloud to it.
Well, but this is all a part of it.
You'd read aloud
to your giraffe.
I'm just talking about
the more sensational things.
Okay, is that your final answer?
And there is a place, there is a hotel.
Yeah, it's called Disney World.
There's a hotel in Africa where,
again, I don't know, I don't
know if these things are,
like, just on the premises.
I don't know the situation.
I'm not advocating, like, pet giraffes.
Like, giraffes need to be in the wild,
but there is a hotel where you eat,
you're in your room, and
you're, like, eating breakfast,
and the giraffes come in
and, like, interact with you.
I think it's giraffes.
I've seen this, yeah.
I've seen a picture of it.
I don't know about the, I don't
know about if its ethical,
so I'm not saying I'm doing it.
If they're wild giraffes that have somehow
just become comfortable with
people, then I might go.
If they're, like, giraffes
that they're keeping
and making interact with people for money,
then I'm not a part of it.
Well, I think that's
where the hotel comes in.
Well, I mean, maybe the giraffes are,
what are the giraffes getting
outta me?
I don't know, yeah.
I'm just saying you're out in wild.
You're reading a book to a giraffe.
Just keep it pure.
You're the one muddying everything.
Just keep it pure, man.
Listen, the world is complex.
And when it, and when it gets attacked,
you can't intervene.
I don't know what I would
do in the case of a,
anything that it can hurt a giraffe
I'm a tell you right now.
is probably not something
I could do something about,
but you as a seahorse man.
I would intervene with my friend
because I'm not a nature documentarian,
and that's why I'm not, because
I want the seahorses to be,
I'm gonna do everything in my
power to protect my seahorses,
well, my seahorse friends.
They're not mine. I don't own 'em.
Oh, so you did go back to seahorse.
Oh, yeah.
I took you back to seahorse.
I thought you went to land horse.
Yeah, that's right.
I could have a, I could have both.
Okay, so tell us what you think.
You know what, you don't have to tell me
what you think about the
controversial things I said.
There's already enough of that.
Just tell us what you think about,
just tell us about
"Octopus Teacher."
What did the octopus
teach you?
Yeah.
#EarBiscuits. We'll
speak at you next week.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.